so here you guys are in the casting
office for now four laps to and art how
did you audition for last one did that
come about this is a devilish grin
proceeded to my answer it was actually
in the living room of this person's
apartment was interesting that's very
unorthodox but I'm you know it's kind of
cool a small beginnings small beginnings
very small humble beginning Chad had
seen me in this one minute flight
festival and then he told me what the
project was and I thought it was cool so
he said want to come down an audition
said sure so I drive down to this place
in culver city this apartment and get in
there and you know we sort of just
talking hanging out for a while but that
it was literally was sitting on a piano
bench and then shooting with my phone
because at the time i'm try remember if
you told me that it was gonna be shot
strictly with an iphone or not and i
thought you know okay those big surprise
he's so he's doing the the the interview
audition with an iphone and i'm kind of
like okay this is gonna be what its
gonna be so picked up a pen off the off
the table and use that as a cigar it was
just kind of goofy but it worked i guess
yeah made it yeah you did good i still
have that audition tape yeah brettly
he's gonna show that somewhere in this
no mom that's frightening yeah good so
what was it about art that you called it
back a second time or just said i had
been working on the script for about a
year like just from a small little idea
of making a short film and then turning
into a web series so I had this
character of this bearded heavyset man
and then I get to this one minute play
and here's art who comes up on stage
this heavyset bearded man who just fit
exactly what I had written and when I
met him after the play it just seemed to
work like I told my other project he
seemed like that type of person and then
when I did the audition it just it just
clicked it was that's what it was you
know I felt like I was pretty lucky have
you had synchronicities
that before isn't sort of the what's the
book The Celestine Prophecy were then
you see are your character and real
flesh and blood no I haven't because
you're sure he's my first oh okay all
right no because of a Shay's character
she was not supposed to be you know do I
didn't write her with you know being
african-american and having these sort
of qualities and but when I met her it
that was where I was like this actually
fits like I like that dynamic kind of
thing so who's those different
you